and one of the challenges you've given
yourself as an actor is a you are with a
dog a lot of the time and you genuinely
get on with this dog I love the dog I
think this is an outtake of you and
brandy it Baird she's done all right
that's enough
right okay okay yeah I'm gonna show
Cheers
down bad girl brandy what is going on
have you put dog food down your t-shirt
or something I don't know I think she
just got I don't know maybe she was
meant to just do that and she got
carried away like the taste of my hair
gel or something good I don't know I had
on yeah I took it as real affection yeah
I am
it's so funny that when them I said
goodbye to the cast and crew on the last
day yeah you know huggin everyone's
remember hugging oh yeah yeah but when I
simplify the dog that's when I nearly
cried because I was thinking she doesn't
know why she's not gonna see me next
week she worked me for so long
so I probably ever estimated how sad the
thought was to not be seen
[Music]